congrats to nicholas sandman
the covington catholic student who
settled a lawsuit today with the
with the uh washington post
i believe it was a 250 million dollar
lawsuit i don't know what
does that mean he gets 250 what does it
mean benjamin
break it down ben avery legal scholar
what does it mean
so they did settle but they haven't
disclosed the terms of the deal
we don't know the terms of the deal but
it's good money is it not
it must be is it big money it's probably
really big
i bet it's big money for
nicholas sandman covington catholic high
school teen of the heart
of the this is when the native american
if you don't remember this folks
uh remember you were somewhere when the
world was a world
you were in your office you're maybe
eating a cold
crazy sandwich this is where you were i
know where you were
you were eating a cold caprese sandwich
which has
the tomato and the tomato had a little
bit of the
white in the middle because it was
winter and you don't love that but it's
the way it is because you just grabbed
this
from the deli in the building you know
the [ __ ] food place in the building
you're eating a caprese sandwich you're
dunking it
it's got a light smear of pesto but you
needed more so you're dumping it in the
balsamic vinegar
and you're eating it and you're really
like god this isn't good it's just not
good it tastes like refrigerator and
you're eating it and then you
looked online and uh you saw
this story about a group of red hat
maga hat wearing kids from covington
catholic a school in kentucky that went
to the march for life in dc
and surrounded a native american man and
beat him to death
because that's what i thought happened
when i first saw how angry everybody was
i said they surrounded this native
american man who was like trying to sing
peaceful songs that the native american
man was like
peace to all the people in the world
i don't know why he's british but the
accents never
come out the way they should
but it's good because it's a white
accent and you can't get angry at that
so this is nathan phillips with his drum
and his british agony ghost and he walks
up
and i love you and then the kids
beat the [ __ ] out of him stomp on his
head
piss in his mouth [ __ ] them not because
they're gay it's just
showing of power i'll [ __ ] him smirk him
in his face
uh bloody him up real good take a [ __ ]
on him
um and then i don't know
and then like light his corpse on fire
and all light
[ __ ] joints uh and then smoked him
and go hey [ __ ] you i'm white what are
you gonna do
um and the old shirts that said like you
know
[ __ ] you uh you know
my land is my land shirts and my land is
my land shirts they sang my country tis
of thee while they stomped him out
sweet land of liver
[Music]
and they were just stomping them out
this is what we believed happened
it's what we thought happened apparently
we were lied to again that is not what
happened
this guy was standing there a bunch of
black israelites
who i like and they are fans of the
program shout out to the black
israelites
yes they are anti-gay and anti-jew but
they're not anti-tim
because i used to do uh tours for the uh
in harlem
and i would see the black israelites and
i would stop my tour bus
and make the people listen to the black
israelites scream about right
uh white people being genocidal monsters
i thought it was a nice break
uh between the apollo theater and then
uh fifth avenue and the apple store
i thought it was a nice break ah we're
gonna stop here and listen to these
three gentlemen dressed like uh ninja
turtles they wear they dress like
splinter
and um so they were yelling at the
covington kids they were like what are
you [ __ ] white face what are you all
doing sucking each other's dicks
i bet it was good yeah i bet it was good
roasting
good roasting of course
liberals are like you know no they
weren't saying
that what so they were roasting the
covenant kids and then nathan phillips
came in with his like you know
the thing they have what's the thing you
have with the drum and they go like this
and it hits both sides of the drum
but do you know what i'm saying i know
what you're talking about it's a it's a
really you know fun you do it
and he comes up and he's like dude you
know he's doing his thing and he's
and he's like i am a native american
what is coming out now what is this i
don't even know what this one is
this is jamaican this is a jamaican one
it just happened i am a native
i'm a native american why and uh i don't
even know how i don't even know
how native americans talk it's very slow
and deliberate right it's like
harm is this it harmer
i'm a wise ne is this richard nixon and
nixon
it's a c.i.a [ __ ]
president can't say jew god damn it
you don't [ __ ] with the cia bob they've
always hated me these [ __ ]
j edgar hoover the kennedy family i
didn't go to the ride schools okay
so then the native american who is not a
jamaican a british person or richard
nixon i just don't know how to do it
but you know how they talk it's like
slow always
because they know things they're wise
they've seen it and they're i forget
what he how he would do it he'd be like
how how
you are a bad white man or something
that's kind of it
you're bad why but then it gets it gets
a little irish doesn't it
doesn't it get a little irish they've
been [ __ ] over more than
anybody really the native americans sure
you got casinos the irish people of
nothing
we just get little by priests and eat
boiled meat and look at our wives
and our wives look like husbands if you
know what i mean
they're disgusting women so
he comes over to the covington kids and
i believe he's beating a drum
in nicholas sandman's face
covington kid and then nicholas sandman
to his uh credit doesn't
while out doesn't punch the guy doesn't
do anything really egregious other than
stand there and smile
as you would if a guy started banging a
drum in your face i would have [ __ ]
freaked out i would have twerked out
if if nathan phillips started twerking
not nathan phillips nicholas sandman but
if both of them started twerking
like straight up twerking it's time for
america to get even crazier do you know
what i mean
we're on this edge of total insanity
let's
let the car fall off it but nicholas
salmon just stood there as this
um elder tribal elder
was confronting him i don't know what
you confront him about but i remember i
tweeted because i didn't know was going
on when it first happened i tweeted i
went
some of these kids need to get shot
because i thought they you know i
thought like this kid was just [ __ ]
with this old indian guy like why you
[ __ ] with this native american dude he
didn't do anything to you
he didn't do it i didn't care that the
kid had a maga hat or he was at the
march for life i mean whatever i don't
good good for you
if you don't believe in abortion good
for you you know
uh whatever you know
but i do i believe in abortion
extortion all the oceans
um we're being silly today folks we
can't we can't it can't be serious all
the time
okay we can't do three hours about judge
salas and the mossad every day
i mean it just can't i just can't handle
it i don't i can't handle it i don't
know what to tell you
yes everybody's gonna kill you sorry
moving on koval's gonna kill you
everything's gonna kill you goodbye next
you know so this kid i thought he [ __ ]
up so i said maybe some of these kids
tuned to get your shot
i like to throw a little pro school
shooting one in there if i can and i so
i tweeted that and then the next day i
had to delete that because i started
watching the footage and i'm like
oh this kid didn't do anything [ __ ]
wrong and
we're being sold a bill of goods a la
jesse smollette whatever by the media
they have an ideological
point to make they don't care about the
facts most normal people agreed with
that
right but then the looney tunes and the
people in my business and
you know the people that just exist uh
in a complete state of being divorced
from reality
for their entire lives which is kind of
amazing when you think about a lot of
people in my business have never
met reality they got famous at like 19
they've had money forever they don't
even understand like
they don't understand how grocery stores
work they don't even stand out like food
comes in it goes in a packet they have
no clue they just open the refrigerator
everything's new and it's colorful and
they bite it
they don't understand the world they
just think when they leave their front
door
there's just people getting stepped on
all the time and and
and they're not being stepped up by the
entertainment industry it's like oil
tycoons and uh bankers and [ __ ] them but
they think those are the only people
that are doing anything wrong
and that uh you know everybody in media
and entertainment is is uh
lovely so these people refuse to really
reverse course they kind of double down
they're like well this guy's the white
guy
the maggot hat he knows what it is
that's the pro-life march he wants to
control women's butt
and then you know people were coming out
that kathy griffin among uh
amongst others were like docs this kid
put his now if you don't know what
happens when you get docs it's really
[ __ ] up
okay when you get doxxed your
information's out there you get loads of
threats
loads of threats i do you know how many
threats i get because since i've been
docked
i have people go call your mother call
this family stop
talking about our family why do you talk
about our family
why do you try to destroy the
relationships that we have
these are trolls doxing me pay us back
money you owe
your license is suspended you bought a
house for 800 000
and didn't pay it back uh i'm getting
mail the government wants to know where
you are
so these trolls dox you i'm happy for
the first time in my life why are you
trying to destroy my marriage
stop talking about me on your [ __ ]
internet show
all of these trolls docs you constantly
constantly dox you they go after you
they go in they even pretend to be your
family
one of them pretended to did one of the
voice things you know the thing they did
to rogan where it's like
literally they can recreate your voice
i've had
family members voices recreated call me
on the phone crying asked me to stop
talking about him on the show so that's
how sick these people
are okay
i didn't want that to happen to this kid
when you're 15 or 16 you do stupid
things i did cocaine this kid went to a
pro-life march
everybody [ __ ] up you know this kid
believes that if we just denied uh
federal funding or whatever to abortion
the world would be better i believed if
i put cocaine up my nose i'd be happy
i was more right than him but it doesn't
matter
everybody believes things in their teen
years that don't work out he believes in
god
i believed in a guy named hector who
used to give us cocaine and then fought
and left one day didn't even tell
anybody where he was going
not nice not right but the point is and
he left you he gave him money for
cocaine he didn't get it he left he
just gone he's gone now he's gone
forever thank you and i'll take my eight
ball when you return sir
sir nicholas uh sandelman what's his
name sandman
sandman followed me on twitter i dm'd
him i said good job
no he doesn't follow me i follow him
follow me back follow me back now
i'll find a way to get all this money
from you i'll find a way to take all the
money
you follow me back you respect me and
you begin to retweet me
pig so
uh nicholas salmon they're trying to
doxx a kid when you're 15
it's just terrifying you're now the
entire media is getting ready to ruin
your life
okay imagine if like the doxing existed
when i was there like
uh tim dillon is doing cocaine again
in the projects with his friend uh they
are now
stealing money from his friend's sister
and they're now stealing money from
tim's mother
again they are purchasing more cocaine
from a guy named
buckshot who they are meeting at the
railroad station
they are going to lay down in their beds
coming down off cocaine furiously
masturbating
what a disgusting thought they must be
doxxed
they must be publicly shamed for this
type of behavior
it's very bad the next day they will eat
barbecue chicken pizza with reckless
abandon
they'll fill their stomachs with it and
real barbecue not this
[ __ ] california kind open pit
barbecue sauce
does anybody know oh let's talk for a
minute about open pit
please because we're going to get back
to nicholas has more money than god in a
minute
i would let that nathan phelps i let a
whole indian tribe
beat and rape me for eight
thousand dollars and this [ __ ]
do you think by the way they look at
this like the white man beat them again
you know nathan phelps and his tribe has
no respect now
they're like oh good you had to beat a
drum in someone's face now they got 300
million
good for now we're just giving them the
land nathan now we're just giving it to
him
how about you keep your drum circle to
yourself
open pit google it get it up now open
pit
i mean he just if you don't instruct him
what to do it's like
it's like you're dealing with a
catatonic here
i wake up i just want to play golf
i'm going to one day i'm going to come
right when he's golfing andrew santino
i'm going to run on the course with a
golf club and beat them
to death okay i'll beat him to death
while andrew santino does the commentary
hopefully tony inch goes there too
tony can do commentary wow you're
getting beaten by a frog
let me tell you about open pit okay open
pit
is a reddish brown barbecue
sauce open pit's blue label so this is
not an ad but i'm i'm telling you what i
like
open pits blue label sauce is unique
flavor that people enjoy right out of
the
bottle
here's why i like it it tastes metallic
it tastes
when you heat it up when you heat open
pit up it
it becomes something that's like
industrial tasting
it is a sauce you put in your mouth it
is the
de facto steak tidbit sauce
on long island the long island official
sandwich is the bacon egg and cheese
yes or yes yes what is the official
lunch
dinner sandwich of long island
i just said it on the show the fish the
lunch sandwich
well the breakfast sandwich is the bacon
egg and cheese
yes what is the lunch
steak tidbits you put the steak on the
garlic bread and you chop
it up you put the melted mozzarella
cheese on top and you brown it
so that and then you chop it up so it's
a little tidbit
in your mouth and what do you do with
the tidbit before you eat it
you put it in the in the [ __ ] open
pit
barbecue sausage sometimes they heat it
up and it's reddish brown and it it
curls your mouth it's like what the [ __ ]
it is a metallic
nasty brackish
just but it's it's my and and my
pizzeria in my town jax which was busted
for selling cocaine
used to call up and they would send you
a white pie we've done this on the
patreon i'm not gonna i'm not repeating
don't repeat every time have a different
thing to say
don't ever repeat anything else
don't ever repeat
so uh this this this
pizzeria would make the barbecue chicken
pizza with
breaded chicken cutlets chopped up they
tossed them with open pit barbecue sauce
they'd throw them on top of a regular
pizza and then throw some mozzarella
cheese on top of that and it was [ __ ]
phenomenal so get in touch with open pit
if you really want to get a taste of the
east coast you do steak tidbits
with open pit barbecue sauce
and some fat steak fries which are not
really that good but that's kind of the
fry
that goes with that sandwich kind of a
fat steak
fry that is not that good but the steak
fries thick and it makes you feel the
pain of the irish
while you eat it um
you don't get this on the west coast
open pit it's primarily in new york so
nicholas sam has now got 250 million
dollars i hope this kid just [ __ ]
wilds out i mean
we don't know if he's got 250. he he
might walk away with 100 mil with all
these different lawsuits
he's going to twitter he's going to the
new york times right
yeah he might get a hundred mill sure
yeah
nice and how old is he i think he's 17.
17 with a hundred sticks
respect what has he got well
he's 18. he just turned 18 it said it on
twitter okay
so ladies you better pop that [ __ ] like
this
he's a christian so you better be
careful maybe make up a chicken pot pie
and
sing about christ whatever you can you
want to get you want to get close to
that dude
he's going to have a lot of bread a lot
of cheddar what's the new one for money
was it guap for a while people said guap
i don't think they say guap anymore
greenbacks greenbacks what are you
nuts it's from like 94.